regardez vous aime pas la moindre idée
du sacré bourbier dans lequel vous êtes
frais y
en a qui osent tout lé meurtrier second
est épié jouera dans le podcast vous
avez toujours votre micro un peu mon
dieu je vais toujours bon en rien les
tiges des rames bien avant le délai de
30 jours pour récupérer mon dépôt de
garantie mais shirel reprend des preuves
n'arrive pas d'apparaître ide en haut à
gauche
seul arme du crime quelqu'un est en
train de jouer avec nous s'il était
simplement de nous faire arrêter la
police sera prêt déjà la porte
pourquoi je dis à ce qu
il faut qu'on retrouve le vrai tueur
cherchons un indice qui nous innocent on
ne peut pas être vues entre à l'entrée
par effraction à moins que personne ne
nous voit en retrait
au nom de dieu
on commence à prendre le coup de pinceau
lui ment on sent que c'est notre
deuxième saison